bon vous le savez je kiffe les gens
comme un destin improbable et surtout
beaucoup de boulot si vous avez regardé
la dernière vidéo de Steven le
prisonnier qui est une histoire très
touchante j'ai vu ça vous a touché vous
aussi on est pareil je pensais pas mais
après cette vidéo j'ai été pris de
passion pour tous les mecs qui adore
l'imposture tous les mecs qui arrive à
me donner ouvertement a des gens mais ça
passe quand même je pensais pas tombé
sur une histoire aussi pour que celle de
Steven et pourtant j'en ai trouvé cette
histoire c'est celle de Frédéric Bourdin
et devine quoi il est français c'est
rare dans les histoires qu'on parle en
français la dernière fois c'était André
the Giant André pendant 10 ans il s'est
fait passer à travers toute l'Europe
plein de fois pour un adolescent perdu
dans le seul but d'attirer l'attention
et d'essayer de revivre une enfance
qu'il n'a jamais eu il a pas fait ça
pour échapper à la justice au pour
détourner de l'argent il a fait ça parce
qu'il avait besoin d'amour c'est un peu
chelou mais c'est aussi un peu mignon et
vous allez voir qu'un jour il se trouve
dans un énorme bourbier qui mène à de
très sombre découverte potentiel bref je
pense que vous allez kiffer mais avant
instagram
oh my god regarde là-bas c'est Brandon
BGO là là je suis trop fan je connais
toutes ses chansons on va le voir direct
salut les girls on peut avoir un
autographe s'il te plaît vous voulez pas
une photo plutôt on n'a pas de portable
bah moi j'ai un vie volée 21 oui ben ça
va te la pète pas non plus pourtant il y
a de quoi c'est le meilleur smartphone
pour les selfies avec son double plage
avant
que là c'est toi qui est en train de
nous faire un placement de produit en
direct c'est comme regarder sa story
mais en vrai
mais du coup on fait comment tu prends
la photo et tu me l'envoies je pourrais
vous l'envoyer avec
mon deuxième téléphone ok je retire ce
que j'ai dit il est bien en train de
nous narguer
52 y a 2 jours d'autonomie de batterie
c'est un truc de ouf les girls non mais
attends j'ai compris tu as de téléphone
car tu vas nous en donner mdr non on se
casse attendez j'ai des liens de
réduction c'est bon on reste en passant
par mon lien en description vous aurez
100 € de réduction sur le vivre au 21
avec une place pour ton concert et
retrouve également le vivo y52 avec
moins 50 € et des écouteurs ok super et
du coup pour la photo où il faisons ça
et n'oubliez pas de me taguer sur les
réseaux arobase Brandon
Frédéric à vouloir changer d'identité
plusieurs centaines de fois son enfance
le 13 juin 1974 en banlieue parisienne à
Nanterre ses parents sont rencontrés à
l'usine mais sa mère va rapidement faire
deux découverte la première et la
deuxième c'est que le père de Frédéric
est déjà marié et il a 6 enfants
et elle se retrouve toute seule du coup
du coup Frédéric et pendant des nuits
entières à tel point que les services
sociaux à cette histoire de Frédéric à
ses grands-parents Frédéric va avoir
beaucoup de mal à s'intégrer a commencé
cette nouvelle vie auprès de ses
grands-parents et donc il va un peu
s'enfermer dans un monde imaginaire et
commencer à inventer des trucs à 5 ans
par exemple ses camarades de classe lui
demande pourquoi son père est jamais là
Frédéric il a pas trop envie d'assumer
la vérité et du coup il dit bah c'est un
espion anglais il est tout le temps en
mission tu vois 00 7 secondes c'est mon
père mec les autres forcément d'y croire
et comme d'un coup et pour la première
fois de sa vie des gens s'intéressent à
lui bah il rentre dans ce cercle vicieux
du il ment les gens s'intéressent il
mange les gens s'intéressent est
carrément au bout d'un moment il sort
des trucs incroyables et ça passe parce
qu'ils sont tous mes gars jeune et donc
il va lui dire qu'il a déjeuné
tranquillement avec son idole Michael
Jackson sauf que par la suite en
grandissant évidemment les gens
commencent à se rendre compte que
Frédéric sort quand même pas mal de
mytho du coup normal plus personne ne
fais confiance c'est comme le proverbe
là si tu crie au loup alors qu'il est
pas là le jour où il est vraiment la
personne viendra t'aider ma mère elle
m'a dit ça après un mytho j'ai plus
jamais menti Cédric a maintenant 12 ans
et là il fait une petite crise d'ado
c'est-à-dire il fout le bordel et vole
des trucs en cours il est donc placer
dans un foyer près de nantes censé le
remettre sur le droit chemin mais ça
marche pas de ouf et c'est là qui
développe un passe-temps à c'est bizarre
il kiffe se perdre en ville et se faire
passer pour quelqu'un d'amnésie chacun
s'est passé en 1990 il a 16 ans et tu
l'as dit je fume et c'est ça qui marque
le début de salon série d'imposture à
l'époque son rêve c'est de vivre au
Royaume-Uni il est persuadé que la vie
est plus belle que tout est mieux où il
fait ce que tout le monde fait pour
aller en Angleterre il rentre dans un
commissariat et il prétend être un
enfant britannique perdu est amnésique
Frédéric frérot ça ne passera pas il y a
une feuille dans ton plan tu ne parle
pas un mot d'anglais fais un effort
apprend l'anglais avant de faire ça mais
de retour au foyer Frédéric qui se dit
putin j'ai kiffé ce qui vient de se
passer quand même ah non plus tarder pas
son sur un jeune homme dans une gare ce
jeune homme prétend est gravement malade
et les dons conduit à l'hôpital c'est
Frédéric vous l'avez compris à l'hôpital
sur son dossier on peut lire le Scénic
il est ni d'où il vient mais le médecin
sont pas cons ils sont médecins lol et
du coup il commence à remonter peu à peu
sa vraie identité et Frédéric sans que
il va se faire griller il préfère tout
en les mettant dans les yeux il dit
pouce on arrête tout voilà je suis un
énorme mythomane je vous ai menti mon
vrai nom c'est Frédéric Bourdin je joue
les 12 et 13 septembre prochain à La
Cigale bref retour au foyer nouvelle
fois je dis mais
quand je leur révèle la supercherie la
leur regard leur incompréhension j'adore
et devient donc addict à ce sentiment de
puissance et là il va plus s'arrêter on
est en 92 Frédéric a maintenant 18 ans
et donc il quitte le foyer 1 ans plus
tard des gens retrouve milieu de la rue
allongé par terre un enfant mais c'est
enfants c'est Frédéric évidemment un
enfant il y a 18 ans les médias sont au
courant de l'histoire ils ont envie d'en
parler parce que là ça fait divers quand
même passer un solide il va y avoir une
émission sur TF1 il s'appelle perdu de
vue et qui va parler de ce mystérieux
cadeau enfant muet retrouvé allongé par
terre au milieu de la rue on sait pas
d'où il vient on sait pas qu'il est la
la quel mystère
mercredi 22h25 sur TF1
[Musique]
et lui kiffe et kiffe tellement que cet
enfant retrouve mystérieusement la
parole du jour au lendemain pour donner
des interviews dans des journaux
vraiment incroyable cette histoire à la
forcément dans les interviews il a voulu
juste toute la supercherie il continue
pas joué le rôle de l'enfant Bekaert la
parole et il explique que si il fait ça
c'est parce que ses impôts sur lui
permet de sentir aimé pendant un court
instant que quand on croit en son
histoire d'enfant perdu est traumatisé
ben on l'écoute on shoot on prend soin
de lui et il adore ça tout au long des
années 90 Frédéric va continuer ce
délire de sa montée des impôts sur
préférée c'est celle où il se fait
passer pour un enfant perdu parce que
c'est elle qui génère le plus grand
pâtissier d'attention autour de lui mais
il a pas fait que ça il se fait passer
pour une fois un dompteur de tigre une
fois un prêtre sauf que Frédéric ils
abusent tellement que les autorités
remarque que depuis quelques années il y
a de plus en plus d'enfants qui se
retrouve perdu dans les rues du coup ils
sont beaucoup plus vigilant qu'avant et
ça pousse Frédéric à passer la frontière
et à se casser en Angleterre et à partir
de là à chaque fois qui se fait cramer
dans un pays il change de pays pour
tenter le coup ailleurs il y a beaucoup
d'énergie à consacrer à ça sauf qu'il va
faire ça tellement de fois dans tes mon
pays différents que c'est Interpol
carrément qui va commencer à enquêter
sur le truc et c'est un vrai problème en
fait parce que ça veut dire que
maintenant n'importe quel pays a accès à
ses empreintes et donc dès qu'ils
trouveront un ado perdu bas au moindre
doute ils auront la confirmation que
c'est pas un ado perdu c'est Frédéric
Bourdin ça complique les plans mais il
reste quand même les médias pour attirer
l'attention et donc en 1995 il a invité
dans une émission de Morandini tout est
possible dans laquelle elle raconte
toutes les impostures et la prod est
tellement touché par ses histoires par
le fait que si il a fait tout ça c'est
pour avoir de l'amour de la tension qui
vont lui proposer des stagiaires en 1997
il se fait griller dans un foyer en
fatigue et si la directrice décide d'en
parler aux autorités les autorités vont
tout de suite checker les empreintes de
7 enfants et le comparer à celle dans le
fichier d'Interpol qui contient les
empreintes de Frédéric bref il va se
faire commencer mes Frédéric un plan
pour sortir de cette fois il va pas se
faire passer pour un enfant perdu mais
pour un enfant qui a vraiment disparu
oui c'est une énorme idée de merde en
plein milieu de la nuit il met la main
sur le téléphone du foyer et décide
d'appeler un numéro spécialisé dans la
recherche d'enfants disparus il se fait
passer pour directeur du foyer et il
prétend qui vient d'accueillir un enfant
à l'instant totalement terrifié sur le
jeu d'acteur de Frédéric cette nuit la
description physique de l'enfant et pour
une fois il va pas mentir sauf qu'il va
se décrire lui-même taille moyenne
cheveux bruns et dents du bonheur
ça passe et la énorme coup de chatte au
bout du fil la personne dis écoutez j'ai
un profil qui pourrait correspondre
certain Nicolas Barclays qui a disparu à
San Antonio Texas il y a 3 ans quand il
avait 13 ans et qui correspond
totalement à la description physique que
vous venez de me donner elle a Frédéric
dans sa tête tout va très vite il dit
mais c'est bon je ne suis plus Frédéric
Bourdin je suis dit que la Barclays j'ai
16 ans et je disparu il y a 3 ans à San
Antonio Texas Frédéric se retrouve une
heure plus tard au bout du fil avec Cary
c'est la sœur de Nicolas
dans un truc c'est un enfer et lui dis
et c'est juste hier et tu ne me demandez
pas comment c'est possible mais ça passe
le lendemain une lettre arrive au foyer
évidemment Frédéric les utilise cette
lettre contient tous les détails de la
faire et une photo de l'enfant et quelle
fut la surprise de Frédéric en
découvrant qui ne ressemble pas du tout
au Nicolas Nicolas il est blond elle a
les yeux bleus et il a pas du tout les
dents du bonheur genre rien de maths
mais il a un signe distinctif il a un
petit tatouage de croix entre les doigts
bon le frérot Frédéric et en plus tout
pour le tout les cheveux en blond il se
fait un tatouage fait maison avec une
aiguille de merde il se refait la Croix
entre les doigts bref il essaie de maths
et le plus possible au physique de
Nicolas sauf qu'il a un problème c'est
qu'il pourra pas changer la couleur du
coup son seul moyen de justifier cette
différence de couleur des yeux c'est
inventer un truc et là on est pas sur sa
meilleure prestation il compte justifier
ça en prétendant s'est fait kidnapper
par un réseau de trafiquants qu'ils ont
droguer envoyer en Europe et que pour
dissimuler son identité ses ravisseurs
aurai mener des expériences chelou sur
lui maintenant au changement de couleur
de ses yeux c'est très bon et que vous
avez pensé à notre problème c'est que il
est nul à chier en anglais
société que ça veut dire qu'il doit
avoir un accent américain hyper vénère
mais non vous en faites pas c'est juste
empêcher de parler pendant toute sa
captivité ce qui fait qu'il a perdu la
santé et que maintenant il parle
différemment et pour ce qui est du fait
qu'il se retrouve dans un foyer après 3
ans elle est en captivité c'est juste
qu'il a oublié de fermer une porte
parce qu'en plus il connaît tout le
détail du dossier puisque on les lui a
envoyé il arrive vraiment à se mettre
dans la peau de Nicolas à tel point
qu'on va lui donner son passeport
américain et qui va prendre l'avion
direction les États-Unis au Texas il y a
même pas eu de test ADN ou quoi genre
c'est bon c'est Nicolas évidemment dans
l'avion Frédéric se dit je suis mort ma
vie est une vaste blague et je vais
finir en taule mais en même temps il dit
que il va enfin savoir ce que ça fait
d'être dans une famille normale où on
s'occupe de lui on est le 18 octobre
1997 la famille de Nicolas l'attends
impatiemment à l'aéroport il manque
juste le frère de Nicolas Jason qui a
quitté la maison familiale juste après
que Nicolas est disparu
on en parle plus tard Frédéric sors de
l'avion toute la famille se précipite
sur sur Nicolas ça lui fait des câlins
ça fond en larme ça saute de joie ça n'y
voit que du feu bordel et tranquillement
la famille se met en route vers la
maison familiale et la prairie qui prend
du recul et dis putin c'est stylée quand
même ce qui m'arrive je voulais me
venger de mon enfance pas ouf et là je
suis aux États-Unis j'ai une nouvelle
famille je vais avoir une vie trop bien
là
non non il a pas compris ce que c'est la
famille de Nicolas c'est une famille
très modeste mais surtout qui a pas mal
de travers par exemple la mer est
totalement addict à l'héroïne et elle
est aussi alcoolique donc ça donne le
ton elle refuse d'accueillir Nicolas
Frédéric chez elle soit disant parce que
ce serait trop de stress pour elle mais
tu viens de trouver ton enfant disparu
il y a 3 ans comment ça il dort pas chez
toi du coup c'est Karine qui va
l'héberger chez elle sur ce que sont
chez elle c'est pas du tout une maison
américaine dans Desperate Housewives
c'est un mobil-home au milieu de la
campagne et c'est pas un mobil-home de
luxe as un mobil-home Jean-Frédéric il a
même pas de matelas il dort à même le
sol weekend malgré qu'il a un travail à
plein-temps et il y arrive à la
perfection il va il va souvent et
ça pendant plusieurs mois
à la place d'un enfant toujours porté
disparu
sa mère elle a l'air très distante elle
a l'air de délaisser énormément il est
issu d'une famille pauvre il était
turbulent à l'école Frédéric se retrouve
aux États-Unis à revivre la même en
France de merde que celle qu'il a eu je
vous rassure ça va pas durer
indéfiniment comme ça récapitulons ce
qu'on a un kidnapping des expériences
médicales à sauvetage miraculeux
forcément il y a plein de production qui
veulent faire du pont autour de
l'histoire de Nikola l'une de ses
productions va faire appel à un
détective chevronné pour les épaules et
un certain Charlie Parker dans la
mission va consister à retrouver où vit
la famille pour les interviews sauf qu'à
l'époque aux États-Unis il y avait pas
trop de règles pour ton âge tu as dire
qu'elles matin car il se lève et il y a
une foule de gens devant sa caravane
c'est une équipe technique d'une boîte
de production quel avec des caméras en
train de la filmer et qui commence à lui
poser plein de questions comme ça alors
qu'elle sortait juste fumer une clope
évidemment elle répond à rien et leur
dis cassez-vous de la on n'est pas parce
qu'on attendait souvenez-vous
contrairement à la famille de Nicolas du
coup lui il va aller leur parler
tranquillement
[Musique]
pour comparer physique dit mais attends
tout le monde n'a que de la merde dans
les yeux là ou quoi ce n'est pas la même
personne c'est évident il a pas eu donc
là il est réussi à les convaincre de
forcer Frédéric est la mère de Nicolas à
faire un test ADN pour n'est pas loin du
Game Over et Frédéric le sais donc avant
de faire le test il prend son téléphone
et contact par cœur et boire un petit
café ensemble et lors de ce café
Frédéric regarde Parker droit dans les
yeux et tu lui dis je suis Frédéric
Bourdin et je suis recherché par
Interpol
on se souvient des premières d'imposture
de Frédéric et on sait que globalement
quand il sait qu'il est foutu il prend
un plaisir incroyable à expliquer la
supercherie il est convoqué au tribunal
et le juge Val condamné à 6 ans de
prison ferme pour avoir usurpé
l'identité de Nicolas et lors de
l'audience Frédéric explique au juge que
malgré ce qu'il a fait lui il reste
persuadé que la mer est le frère de
Nicolas connaissent la vérité et savent
qui est vraiment arriver à Nicolas
Frédéric a dit que un soir il était avec
sa mère fictive donc qu'elle était
complètement bourré et que elle lui a
dit tu es même pas mon fils et elle lui
aurait même le relais des grands teki
putin tu es qui si c'est vrai ça manque
que globalement elle sait depuis le
début que c'est pas Nicolas là qu'elle a
retrouvé c'est un imposteur qui prétend
être son fils et qu'elle aurait fait le
choix de ne rien révéler à personne et
certaine qu'elle est responsable de ce
qui est vraiment arrivé au Petit Nicolas
et que du coup prétendre que cette
personne et son fils bah c'est le
meilleur alibi plus personne dans quel
sur la disparition de son fils elle est
à l'abri ses théories on est dans la
théorie pour ne rien arranger on
découvre dans les rapports de police que
Jason et sa mère ce serait embrouillé
extrêmement violemment les jours qui ont
la disparition de Nicolas si violemment
que la police a dû intervenir et c'est
après c'est énorme embrouille que Jason
aurait quitté le domicile familial avant
de devenir un énorme accro à l'héroïne
lui aussi bref vous l'aurez compris il y
a un mystère autour de cette affaire qui
semble dépassé tout le monde et j'ai une
mauvaise nouvelle à vous annoncer en
fait on n'en sais pas plus Jason depuis
est mort d'une overdose et vu qu'il y
avait aucune trace ni témoins lors de la
disparition de Nicolas bas la police a
pas réussi à avancer dans l'enquête et
globalement ça me rend fou est-ce qu'ils
étaient au courant qu'est-ce que c'est
eux qui l'ont muté ça me rend fou on n'a
jamais le fin mot de l'histoire en
revanche on a eu des excuses de Frédéric
quand même c'est pas mal il s'est excusé
pour tout le mal qu'il a pu faire à
cette famille il l'aura rappeler que
voilà s'il a fait ça c'était pas du tout
pour leur faire du mal volontairement
c'est juste que il voulait sentir aimé
et ses excuses le juge les as entendu et
il a décidé après coup de main vers le
jugement c'est en prison ferme excuse
frero ce que tu as fait gravissime
prison bref on a pas de news de 7
familles qui apparemment cache quelques
mystères mais par contre on a Frédéric
donc il sort de prison 2003 il retourne
en France et dans un supermarché il se
calme il comprend ses erreurs du passé
il comprend que s'il a pris 6 en prison
ferme c'est pas pas du tout on est en
2005 il a 30 ans mais il décide de se
faire passer pour un ado qui s'appelle
Francisco Fernandez Fernandez il prétend
être orphelin et réussi à se faire placé
en foyer impôts de s'arrête jamais c'est
incroyable et réussi à se faire inscrire
un collège ok tu me diras à 30 ans dans
des classes de 4e il y a des Français la
tête et regarde cette vidéo qui était en
classe de 4e et leurs voisins de classe
c'est un mec de 30 ans qui a fait 6 ans
ferme de prison les cours de maths c'est
plus la même pas un bon écoutez le coup
de Francisco là c'était vraiment dernier
après ça il s'est rangé pour de vrai en
2012 des journalistes ont demandé
pourquoi il avait arrêté pourquoi il est
pas recommencer et il a expliqué que il
a adopter un chat et qu'il fallait bien
qu'il s'en occupe ok Frédéric si vous
connaissez des imposteurs au frais leur
un chat ça résout tout apparemment mais
attendez c'est pas tout après toutes ces
années Frédéric à trouver l'amour le
véritable amour avec un grand A en fait
une femme a vu Frédéric dans une
émission et elle est tombée amoureuse de
lui du coup elle a contacté et un an
plus tard ils sont mariés et ils ont eu
un enfant et c'est là que la vie après
un autre tournant pour Frédéric
Nicolas par contre toujours au niveau
j'espère qu'il vous a plu
pour que tout soit passé comme ça s'est
passé là je suis content de me dire
qu'il a arrêté de faire ça c'est
peut-être il a trouvé la paix il était
temps après tu me tiens au courant si je
trouve une autre histoire incroyable de
imposture ou pas mais je reste à la je
vous souhaite une excellente journée et
une nuit allez bisous
ta grand-mère
agar.io
[Musique]